amnesty international estime à plus de
2000 le nombre de tués par mois 6 et
pharmaceutiques cette année la vente une
personne se soit celles ci n'ont pas la
nouvelle arena
vous allez trouver le candidat idéal
pour une démonstration
c'est un truc pour toi avec ça tu peux
gagner tous tes prochains combats
pourquoi moi sinon on en prend plein
dirais que toi gens sont ainsi mis la
note
qu'est ce que tu veux ses ennemis
pamiers la liberté la justice tu t'en
fous je peux le faire d'argent mais
[ __ ] veilleux merde c'est la
révolution dehors
comme contre nous
[ __ ] je peux pas garder je préfère ne
rien ares est vivant on a trouvé le
patient zéro
le seul qui pouvait supporter leurs
[ __ ] de pompes magazine interdite et
géo des milliards pour eux mais
laisseront pas partir
je crois que ça a de la gueule de dire
merci
oui
trouvez moi ça y est
ne manquait qu'une étincelle à la
révolution j'aurais j'avais parié sur
lui